a year ago we were together we were
talking about all the work that the
Clinton Foundation does around the world
what they're working on currently what
would you say is your number-one
priority the Clinton Foundation what my
our focus right now that our new focus
is trying to do more about the opioid
epidemic yeah
I have been working let me just say a
few words about all ask yourselves all
these questions first of all how many of
you know someone who is either died or
who had someone in their family died of
opioid overdose raise your hand look
look okay Hillary and I Hillary and I
have five friends who's lost children
this is no respecter and by the way one
was african-american - were white are
Kansans one was an Indian whose father
was an immigrant who did terrifically
well and one was a Kosovar Albanians and
we're going to lives on my street and
what bothers me about this I started
working that when the young brilliant
wonderful Indian American man who was
working for Hillary at the State
Department dine and have his girlfriend
told him after that he drank four beers
together he should pop on oxycontin it
would give him a bus if you fall asleep
that can kill you because any mixture of
opioids with any kind of alcohol
dedenne's the part of your brain that
tells your body to breathe while you're
sleeping
now I have asked all kinds of people
including a 20 year old young guy that
just got out of rehab a couple weeks ago
that saw him and anybody ever tell you
that in school in high school or college
no I
and he said believe it or not I ask the
same question and the people I was in
rehab with and the answer was no
so I'd spent most of my time trying to
make excuse me narcan or naloxone more
readily available at the lowest possible
price to the people who have to
distribute it and also working with a
wonderful little company called adapt to
get free nasal spray naloxone container
to as many colleges and high schools in
the country as we could as quickly as we
could now the good news is I don't know
if you see this stuff work it's like
mind boggling it's like a miracle you've
got somebody your swears dead and I mean
they're back in a minute the problem is
someone has to be there and so what I've
tried to do now is I we work with the
Bloomberg School of Public Health at
Johns Hopkins in Baltimore we just came
back from Baltimore doing our third
annual opioid summit and we're trying to
do more first to educate people on the
basic public health of it believe it or
not all of the young people every person
you know you should tell you cannot mix
and opioid with any level of alcohol of
any kind without risking your life and
it's do people don't know they don't
know that and if you see somebody do it
you should slap them around so they
can't go to sleep I mean whatever you
have to do throw a bucket of water on
yeah just basic stuff so we're trying to
do prevention we're trying to keep
people off of it and then we've got
trying to go out in and create public
health networks with what budget we've
got so we're doing our best to go out
and try to figure out how with whatever
money we've got we can build out some
basic treatment and basic education and
get the universities and colleges
involved everywhere so we can keep
everybody alive and that's the most
important thing you got a chance as long
as you're breathing we but you need to
tell people these things and make sure
they know
ninety thousand people a year are dying
it's it's an incredible 90 people a day
I'm sorry over 60,000 people this year
yeah it is an insane epidemic that we're
experiencing right now and I wish we had
I wish we had more time because you I've
never talked to a guest who has more
facts at their fingertips than you do
and has more important things to say
[Applause]
I'll tell you something else it was your
doing you're doing the Lord's work I
will tell you that and I'll say
something else it's been it's been a 25
year wait to talk to you but it's been
worth the wait and I will be for real
honor yeah for more information this is
important stuff more information visit
[Applause]
www.reimaverick.com
you